my name is Danny Kendall I'll be
chairing the meeting in accordance with
the rules and procedure as set out in
the front cover of your agendas tonight
before we get started just a few bits of
general housekeeping if that's okay to
remind members of the public please to
tell the mobile phones off so there'll
be no distractions later and to make her
be aware that tonight's meeting is being
both filmed and recorded so it's going
out live on the website tonight as we
speak
and it will also be available for you to
review at your leisure on the website
tomorrow should you wish to do so a few
general introductions on my far right is
Liz divorce Co from committee services
stratford district then mason ash who's
a legal representative tonight then on
my left is Karin taped our Planning
Manager for the evening then Andrew
Watson Erin whether stone and Alison
will air with us who are all planning
officers here at Stratford district or
presenting various cases for us as the
evening goes on right so with that being
said if we go to item one apologies for
absence thank you
disposed of interests councillor Perry
for the application number sixteen
forward slash zero one nine three eight
item five I also admire that as well not
the ward member for that ward anymore
but I have expressed my opinions on it
so therefore I will step down from the
committee for that meeting for that item
and accounts are crumpled chair for me
councillor Don Thank You Sharon
interested member and also in item
number eight due to work connection
thank you so item seven or eight any
other declarations of interest should be
stepping down for both items and yes
yeah thank you
excellent so on to item three confirm
the minutes of the second of August and
I signed those as a true record
thank you I should do that at the end
right in that case get our first
application tonight this is item four on
the agenda
and is found on page 15 this is our
application reference 17 / 0 1 7 4 4 /
ful and it's for pit stop cafe au café
has strength on the pass more than March
and it's for the change of use from a
3-2 Prestige Car Sales the sending
officer Andrew Watson 100 so to you so
this is a resubmission of an application
which was refused early this year and
the main changes are they to the scheme
like the landscaping one front again
it's far away the restriction on the
number of cars to be sold and their
report also I likes the fallback
position concerning the site and it's
lawful use for permission of sorts
changes to the site to a from a3
restaurant with car sales to Tsui
generous use and the retention side
clearance which is include cell
stripping importation of article and
direction on perimeter fence at at the
cafe the application site was in the
countryside between strata enforcement
shifts on store the application site is
858 meters northeast of Stratton and 1.6
2 miles southwest of ships turn the site
also lies in the cops'll fringe special
landscape area website shows notice area
photograph of site which is a little out
of date but you've got phosphate running
north to south that's summation of a
plan from from the agents as Lyme
disease at the moment and that's the
proposed layout planned now with more
landscaping around the site so more
there's more
a Trojan plant or the mix has been
increased reasonably increased around
the site and that's also at the frontage
now if you can see where they cross the
bottom we've got the Green Street
because that's the edge rail which will
be built so so grown around a timber
fence rather than power-save metal fence
so a galvanized steel fencing and that
would be no higher than 1.2 meters and
the scene you see on the cross section
the car is used to love a fence but
below the lights are the trees so that
then we've got some what the sights like
now so far in the soil stripping
everything else this was taken one last
application come in but nothing else has
we've done to the site since then and
that's looking on fast way up the road
it's the fence on the Left ferry which
you can see which is to be taken down
and the similar fencing to door not in
the picture and that's just the internal
parts of site say the application is has
been considering was recommended for
refusal on the grounds of sustainability
sorry sorry I'm just like to say that we
have done an update sheets but regarding
the legal position following the
information we got from the applicant
solicitors thank you okay so let's go to
our first speaker on this application is
councillor is he Hazelwood please from
strike on the Faust Parish Council
welcome counselor right you say welcome
back so yes you have three minutes you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end and I'll give you a sort of an
indication in the last ten seconds if
that's okay press button just in the
middle Oh
press the light leads to come on just
press that again or do they get the
parish council supports this application
a change of use as does this time our
district councillor Jo Barker this site
has been a cafe or restaurant over many
years and the businesses have repeatedly
failed times have changed and the siting
of a cafe here no longer generates
enough custom to succeed it's a
brownfield site next to a petrol station
the land cannot simply be left derelict
and although a car sales business may
not seem an obvious use of the site that
our benefits which we the parish council
consider to outweigh the disadvantages
the proposed car sales business is not
to catch passing trade but will be
selling expensive so called prestige
cars where much of the business is
conducted online it is therefore not
going to lead to garish signs and
excessive traffic entering or leaving
the site the parish council had already
agreed with the applicants agent that a
proposed landscaping scheme would be
implemented and maintained for five
years which would make the site much
less industrial looking and more in
keeping with the surrounding landscape
with this revised application the
applicant has in addition reduced the
height of the green link fence and
proposed wooden fencing hedge and trees
along the roadside instead of the
sealing fence we consider this to be an
improvement the applicant has an
addition agreed to not more than forty
cars for sale on site the main reason
for refusal of the previous application
was the lack of sustainability however
we failed to see how the land being left
to become derelict is
approval the proposed landscaping
schemes impact on the surrounding
landscape would be a great improvement
the fact that there is no public
transport available to get to the site
is here not relevant customers turning
up to view expensive cars will be very
unlikely to want to get there by bus
when it was a cafe or restaurant it was
meant to pick up passing traffic people
travelling by car not by public
transport or on foot potential local
employees for example from the village
of Stratton enforce are unfortunately
used to the fact that there is almost no
public transport available to them to
get to any kind of work at all and this
will in fact be only a 20-minute walk
for them where it's still a cafe or
restaurant they would be in exactly the
same position this is already a
brownfield site with very limited
possibilities whole development
providing that the landscaping scheme is
put in place maintained for at least
five years that there is no flood
lighting and the number of cars for sale
is limited to 40 we consider this
business use to be acceptable we wanted
the number to be restricted and we in
fact proposed down to 50 but the
applicant is now saying 40 we'd be very
pleased with that because obviously we
don't want rows and rows of cars you
better check with him but I think about
10 was about the number suggested I
don't know there may be more
in your comments you also mentioned the
damage to the adjacent farmers learn to
be made good yes I think that that has
been agreed it's it's some of the
hedging was removed at the back yeah any
further questions if not that's
everything thank you very much okay go
to our next speaker which is the
welcome also so you have three minutes
remain seated for any questions at the
end over to you since last time my
client sought advice from a leading
barrister unfortunately a legal opinion
was only published on your website
yesterday she concludes that refusal
efficient was unreasonable and
recommends an appeal an application for
full award costs that might sound like a
CREP but is not it is important the
members are fully aware that an appeal
would be a waste of the council's money
from stretched resources planning should
be working positively together as
required by the MV PF and hence I'm here
tonight even though an appeal would be
more lucrative and it's also my wife's
birthday so we listen to the issues
raised by members June finally balanced
debate last time but I sought to address
them in this revised application members
disliked the style of the fence last
time the frontage is the most visible
and we have changed this to a post from
my own fence in keeping with the rural
landscape the rear fence will reduce to
2 metres that's before and there's not
any Commission members one show about
the landscaping scheme in the early
years so we have briefed top the scheme
to be effective from day one and provide
an illustration of how they will look in
the first year just to be clear no
consent weld the planning officers can
not require any planting at all the
application proposes no fog lighting as
we don't need it with a petrol filling
station additional security will be
provided by small infrared CCTV down
cameras these will be hardly visible
under the eaves of the building with no
wires one counts of the mentioned the
glare from wind screens I can see where
he's coming from but unlike solar power
farms the Sun penetrates the glass and
it's not reflective hence no highways
objections cars will be mostly screened
by the vegetation and mostly part to the
rear the building however to further
adjust such concerns the application
specifically proposes a limit of 40 cars
for sale councillor kendall mentioned
sustainability and that is a key issue
my planning statement comprehensively
addresses this issue and pre-breathe the
proposed use is the best viable use of a
vacant brownfield site it would also
significantly reduce car trips compared
to its approved use as a cafe and in
women retail the fallback position is
highly material in weighing up the
benefits of the proposal and cannot be
divorced from planning policy which it
complies with in any event there are
numerous local presence policy CS 23
stakes in the refuse enosis seeks to
control large-scale retail development
so not relevant and appropriately
applied yeah this is the only real
objection by the planning officer it
also does not make any sense as a
property can you be used now for retail
use conversely the planning officer
agrees that are we no additional harm to
the landscape or residential immunity
and so acceptable in all other respects
the proposal is strongly supported by
the parish council and there are no
objections is it also supported by
councillor Barker because it is the best
and lowest impact to use of the site the
proposal of one of local planning issues
and a local community want to see the
proposal come to fruition
it seems the planning officers would
tell satellite live Aiken that this will
attract anti-social behavior and would
be completely contrary to guidance in
the MPPs thank you for your time
I think delighted to answer any
questions thank you
good evening mr. Keatley I just wondered
whether you could just give a little bit
more detail on the landscaping the the
plantation and the height just a bit
more detail on that and will they be
sort of maturely when they're planted
will there be mature and what sort of
hike did they grow and difficulty
because obviously it's the plan is so
large so when you reduce it down you
don't see the detail but the trees for
example will be heavy standard trees so
they're probably about as heavy as you
can get in terms of planting trees into
into a site and again the hedgerow you
know will be mature in box standard from
the start so what you see there in the
green is what will be planted in at the
first year of the development the
outline is is the maturity level but
what you can see in the green there is
how it will be and within a year
you probably heard the question is we
focus on how many jobs are to be created
yes submission they'll be up to ten jobs
and some of these will be four times
some will be part-time
up to maximum of ten jobs we have two
things one with regards to selling cars
certain amount of visibility of what is
there I know that people driving past
will see the fence etc but no cars but
still people are inquisitive what's
going on behind the fence and secondly
are you in part of a larger give the
best answer that I can I mean in terms
of I think it's really important to
understand the operation and I I didn't
want to repeat what I said at the last
committee but as you've asked a question
about seventy-five percent of sales are
internet-based so people see the car
they decided that they want it they
speak to the salesman he talks them
through the car in great detail and only
then do they come and see the car at
which point they actually pay a deposit
I'm 99 percent of the time they're happy
because it's been described accurately
and
they go with the car and if they're not
happy then I'll giving the money back
obviously but there's very few cars are
sold the passing traffic specifically
with the style of cars that was selling
here's a question for us it's okay it's
a common name it did have one operating
on a small basis why he's desperate
ticket on the site because you can't
sell any cars of them that's okay any
further question is from a pity
no mr. Goodley thank you very much thank
you I don't see counselor barter in the
audience for no sir in that case mr.
Gillie thank you very much we can move
them to points of clarification seddie
yes counsel bonds I was just we were to
approve the application is the
conditions for the fence there was
conditions for the fence as it is at the
moment but it's coming down is that
correct
are we the if we were to agree we would
have to agree different conditions for
the Pens
so if we were minded to to grant the
application you're saying early yeah and
row the the the changes to the fence are
already part of this application aren't
they so that the defense will be lower
and yeah so if you were to approve it we
could write the condition to make sure
that I've I've done I'm within
appropriate time periods as well it's in
nineteen bullet point yeah the letter
was from one person parties objections
and part it is that they are supporting
the users proposed the object and
mainland I think it was an enforcement
case to start with
you didn't mention the impact on the
character of the landscape has been the
reason either now the application was
submitted with a landscape assessment
and we've looked I've looked at that and
consideration and don't think it'd be
impact on the landscape is something
that we could sustain on refusal to the
debate council bonds well I said I'm a
bit like the parish council I support
this they can't see what else we can do
to a site teaching a special area he's
on the top of a hill is on a fast road
they wouldn't want a pig farm there but
and the caffeine obviously didn't make a
profit with the landscaping that's being
put forward that's why I asked about the
fence I would be quite happy to propose
it that's not what the opposite said but
I think it's the site that noticed me
doing something to it I think this would
be in my eyes as good of goers anything
I I have some concern about security but
that's not you know in the planning
terms that's why the fence I spoke about
that aren't quite a peep of those
approval if you want thank you I'll take
that as a proposal we'll come back to it
in a moment
councillor fielding I'm slightly
concerned that he's striking in rugby
and that failed but on the other hand
the fact as a cafe the amount of traffic
that when it was flourishing a few years
ago
there must have been a lot of cars
coming off the very fast bit of the fast
and going into the cafe this would in my
opinion be a lot safer with that one
with less cars turning into the into the
site as stated they need to pay a
deposit before they can basically come
in and view
take that there counselor Perry Thank
You Jay this application is a good
example of actually the applicant
listening to our great concerns when it
first came forward to the committee
where we were very concerned about the
industrial type of fencing that
surrounded the site to me they've
they've obviously listened to what we've
had to say they've had further
discussions with the parish council and
I think to be honest with you where it
is at the moment it's a it's a derelict
brownfield site a bit of an eyesore
because it's on the top of a hill
there's no objection from highways and I
think the landscaping treatment because
of the maturity that they are proposing
I don't have a problem with this
application and I'm I'm minded to go
against the officers recommendation and
go for support because I think it's
generating some more jobs for the area
and that and I think it will improve the
actual site I just like to second what
councillor Paris said actually because
it moved its derelict it's not bringing
any business in and it can only improve
what's happening there and also it might
bring trade to the surrounding areas as
people drive out to view the cars so
again I'm going to go against the
officers recommendation if there's no
one else counselor we get the right
conditions in place with this one we
need the mature tree a condition in
there
we need a condition in about lighting
and CCTV and anything else that the
officer might recommend yes if ya guess
you've both heard what we're looking at
here so it's weird likely to go with it
I think which is the conditions
regarding trees would that be part of
the standard set of conditions or not
already have to add those are separately
I say we what we thought of is writing
or amending the standard landscaping
condition to fit this sigh of a plan
that was submitted then puts a lunch a
maintenance condition I'm support that
that but ten year period or until the
suma okay you'd be happy with that
calibrate the every standard mature the
spec is every standard trees all the
spec specification is well laid out on
that plan yes counselor Bowen says the
proposed are you happy with those
amenities yes however you want to word
sort of intimated that way when I was
going but I do clear it is an open
society teas on the top of the hill the
more landscaping the better but I feel
the opposite will be able to address
that my concern was leaving the fence to
buy which was you know obtrusive and
thank you council fielding you're also
content thank you
right should we go to the vote it's been
proposed that we grant the application
with the conditions that have been
mentioned as well all those in favor
please show thank you the committee
therefore results to grant application
reference seventeen / 0 1 7 4 4 / ful we
now move to item 5 and the swirl handout
well yeah well whilst Aaron's getting a
presentation thank you we just fight for
cancer advanced to come back and we'll
move on to item five on the agenda which
is 16 / 0 1 9 3 night - fall so bargain
booze 12 Warrick Road was born the
change of the use from a1 retailer to
trust 3 Class A 3 restaurant an eruption
of flu the application science
identified by the black dot on this plan
the application site lies within the
built area boundary limits for wells
bond settlement and falls within the
identified commercial core the
application site falls within the extent
of the wells one conservation area at
identified by the pink line on this plan
a number of listed buildings line within
close proximity of the site identified
in bread the application site comprises
of a two-story building with existing
retail use at ground floor and a flat
above to the side will be other building
lies a yard area plan information is
sought the change of use of the ground
floor unit to a restaurant and for the
erection of a flue to the side of the
property
this slide shows existing a proposed
elevations at floorplan sorry
pilot restaurant seeks to accommodate 38
covers within the existing retail sales
area in this area just here an existing
store to the rear is proposed to be the
kitchen the location of the flue is
shown to be adjacent to the access along
the yard area to the right of the image
plan also identifies where the refuge
may be stored refuse here flew here
kitchen and covers
this tighter is existing and proposed
elevations the plans have been amended
since the application was considered at
Planning Committee in January of this
year a proposed flu has been revised to
be set proximately 2.3 meters above
ground level proposed flu would be
finished with a brick effect flu cover
and protect beyond the existing roof
slope by approximately 1.5 meters
annotations have also been provided on
the revised plans to identify the width
of the access to the side of the
property as approximately two point one
meters so just looking on the plans here
flu is just to the left just projecting
1.5 meters above the roof slope two
point three meters from ground level
just here and two point one
approximately meters for the access to
the side this slide shows a photograph
which was taken from work Road looking
towards the application sites the
approximate location of the proposed flu
is identified by the red arrow this
photograph was taken from the Warwick
Road looking towards the application
site to the right of the property is the
access to the yard area just behind the
gates shown about here this photograph
has taken from Church Street looking
towards away of the application site the
approximate location of the flu is
identified by the red arrow you can see
just about here and the flatter birdie
can see just about here this image shows
the openings and the yard area to the
side of the building looking towards a
Warwick Road so this is the yard the
access and the stairs up to the flat
above the openings you see here this
line identifies areas associated with
the revised parking survey which was
submitted in April of this year for a
number of updates which have been
circulated on the update sheet the
recommend a genetic ramp planning
permissions subject to the conditions
and notes outlined on pages 36 37 and 38
of the committee agenda
thank you speaker you choose catch the
Christine Michael from was born in
Walton parish council hello Michael
obviously you've got three minutes would
you like warning okay yes please I would
thank you thank you thank you at the
January meeting councillor Bolton
outlined to you the parish councils
objections to this proposal it was said
then that the Environmental Health
Department had no objections however
could I draw your attention to one extra
condition it has recommended since then
which is all windows and doors to remain
closed to prevent fugitive odor
emissions how realistic will that
condition be to keep or to enforce
especially in summer the ducting
manufacturer also states that odor
reduction will only work if a rigorous
daily cleaning routine is followed who
is to say this will be done and what
redress will the flat owner have if it
is not I won't say anymore about the
amenity issues serious though they are
but I would like to refer to the new
parking survey I was expected this shows
parking stress levels are much higher
from the previous survey because it was
over a weekend reaching a hundred
percent in Warwick Road at times but in
other roads there is still virtually no
parking stress if you don't know the
roads in question you could assume this
means there is a cause of free parking
there for the taking the officer says
that she has raised concerns about
whether all the parking spaces
identified can be used and I can say
simply they cannot for example in Zone
one Church Street is on the one-way
system the survey says the Northside has
30 spaces and parking stress is zero but
in practice no driver in their right
mind would park on that side except on
the pavement I live on Church Street and
I know cherry orchard is a narrow lane
and the survey says there are 18 spaces
on the east
side and 0% parking stress that is
because there is no room for cars to
park on both sides of the road and still
that traffic through and we've had a
warning just this week from the fire
service about parked cars impeding
emergency vehicles there are similar
issues with the roads in zone 2 suffice
it to say if this survey were restricted
to roads where the average driver would
consider parking safely and
considerately for a couple of hours it
would show those roads are already
subject to very high parking stress as
discussed in January
the highway department asked for the
removal of the take away business as a
condition because of parking concerns to
my mind these concerns still remain once
you consider that the roads around the
property of not realistic parking
options for restaurant visitors and that
they are enough to warrant a continued
objection as the Parish Council has
stated warning it was in the press after
they tried to attend an incident in kind
turn and couldn't get the vehicle
through because of parked cars and so
they put out a general warning for
responsible parking and drivers but it's
very relevant in Wales for me because we
have quite a few roads that are narrow
which is which is the road where the
fabricator couldn't get down it was in
kind and actually but they put out a
general warning to the area not to do
with Wells bore no but it was just a
timely comment no comment
okay yeah thank you hence the micro
answer that's kind thank you we move on
to our next speaker
she's mr. Xu Yates if mr. Dee answers
here I think I I think I recognize him
from last time is that right mr. Yates
no for three minutes so if you will give
your warnings put about ten seconds go
if that's okay it's pretty thank you
thank you I'd like to bring to your
attention an issue of material planning
considerations surrounding litter and
refuge in the twenty third of the second
2017 I sent Allison young pictures of
the driveway with my van to show how
bins obstruct access and how the flue
would do the same you should have these
pictures in front of you as I asked her
to send them on the bins for the shop
are the are only allowed to be stored
adjacent to the building in layman's
terms of speech to the side of the
building this means if I have to move
the bins on to the public road and leave
them there every night when I park my
car this surely breaches planning and
should be addressed in more detail the
plans proposed talk about a step outside
the front and that wheelchair exit
access and ambulant visit visitors with
mobility needs will be will need
assistance shifted into the premises
under the Disability Discrimination Act
1995 is a suitable access for people
with disabilities and this is another
planning matter has this been addressed
at any point regarding antisocial hours
as persisters letter by the covenant of
the least a freeholder has agreed that
by quote it is not allowed to do or
commit or suffer to be done or keep in
or upon the retained
premises any which may be or become
nuisance annoyance or cause damage or
inconvenience the tenant in other words
if the current shot hours changed to 11
p.m. there is a breach in the dese along
with the flue extraction of fumes over
mile and other residents in the
community are also affected in this
factor on the 12th the 6th 2017 alison
young put him writing that plan
commissioners must be granted on the
basis of it as being reasonable legally
the freeholder cannot alter the
construction of the building without my
permission
and additionally he cannot extract fumes
over my land change the hours or blocked
my access with bins so can you please
explain to me how this is a reasonable
reasonable to grant permission for
construction which cannot be constructed
legally and which breaches litter
planning regulations regarding parking
I've sent photographic evidence taken
between the six the six the eleventh of
16 and the ninth of the eleventh sixteen
of a lack of spaces during the relevant
hours sure illustrators question to our
Highway survey that was done
additionally the overall planning
application has expired can someone
explain to me why a decision has still
been discussed as an expired application
I have my legal letters I have a letter
from the mortgage advisor photographic
evidence of parking of the bins being
used and issues of breaching planning
guidelines please be so kind to address
these issues today terms any particular
lift the litter and bins
please justify why no solution has been
offered I live above the restaurant this
oppose restaurant the shop so yeah
that's the gates yeah yeah yeah the
weight of the really build your wheelie
bins underneath the staircase as they
are now but obviously they're new bins
they've asked they're going on the the
front of the staircase there I gave
Alison
which is to prove that when the van is
in that in that space there that you can
see there is no there is no space which
was never nothing was addressed on that
matter and in the plans if you look at
the aerial view their building on the
left-hand side up in the picture when
you look at the plans they're not
actually it's not actually on the plan
so it's misleading so it looks like
there's a 2.1 gap all the way down the
back of there okay having lived in the
in Church Street of back in O 5 they
used to be a lovely smell from the
bakery on the corner the back gate is
that where you bring in your van to park
yes and worst thought amused that is
referred to in the four news that's
possibly behind then it's nothing to do
with
you're terrified so it's just in that
area here so on the end the new
development in this location it's not
it's not adjacent to they prefers
restaurant and that's going to be extra
parking is that or would that be extra
parking in the village I just want to be
absolutely clear what we're talking
about here if you live in the flat above
yeah
the courtyard you said with your
property in your statement correct I own
the leasehold of the courtyard the
grounds of stairs and first floor flat
because that's not where he's proposed
Demong on the plan that's where they are
on that's and he's proposed to obviously
bigger bins due to the fact that the
increase in waste that they are frozen
at the moment they have to have
reasonably sized bins which is they have
one one bin which is the black bin you
don't have to have big four wheeled unit
on the street no because it hasn't
started the wishing to get planning
permission of the for the rest Roy is he
the freeholder here's a so he's bought
the whole building subject a noise which
includes your lease I bought the lease
that owns I own the lease over the over
there he owns the ground they shop it
the he owns the shop and then the
freehold obviously because you can't
split no you can't split them you can't
yeah
they watch em just so clarified that
some of the points is raised will be
brought to a 10 points of clarification
body officer okay thank you thank you
very much thank you could move on to the
applicants agent mr. Steve Olsen please
yeah six minutes
catch the van sir you with us yep thank
you
six minutes you've got yeah you get
twice the time to previous that's why I
won't be that long oh good thank you
very much good evening my name is Steve
Olsen I am a chartered architect at
Brock Charles and we're agent for the
applicant you may remember we presented
this application to you in January this
year when further traffic surveys were
requested well though wells borne is a
large vibrant village the landlord has
still been unable to find any
replacement retail tenant for more than
the last two years now and the premises
remains empty we suspect this coincides
with the opening of the new large
Sainsbury's in May 2015 being less than
one mile away from our site the planning
application is recommended for approval
as the typical concerns of any
restaurant premises have been completely
satisfied related to parking disturbance
nuisance the flu design extracts mails
and fan noise the applicant has
addressed these concerns the
satisfaction and with the support of the
council planning in highways departments
as well as environmental health and
especially the historic environment
officer as the premises within a
conservation area being surrounded by
retail and commercial premises the
restaurant will open when these premises
closed so the existing on street parking
will not be compromised the detailed
series of traffic surveys carried out
during the proposed restaurant opening
hours proved beyond hearsay that there
is an abundance of free of the evening
parking
available in the area there is no
objection from highways recognizing that
there is sufficient parking capacity
within 200 metres of the site and beyond
to comfortably accommodate the parking
demands of the proposed restaurant as I
mentioned the sites within the
conservation area so the extract system
has been designed with both the
conservation officer and environmental
health the flue is concealed in a GRP
brick effect cover which has been
successfully used on listed buildings
previously the flue position is set back
at the furthest point of the building
away from the road to minimize any
visual impact when viewed through the
narrow gap between the existing
buildings it is also two point three
meters above the shared side access
although tenant agreements are not a
material consideration as a planning
matter as confirmed to the council
solicitor the landlord is legally
allowed to install this flue and store
refuse bins for the restaurant an
acoustic engineer has submitted a SAN
report which confirms the extract system
includes a series of carbon filters and
noise reduction silences all noise
generating equipment is located
internally and there is a low-speed fan
noise of just 32 decibels externally
though this is much lower than the
existing background noise level to
satisfy burning to regulations approval
an acoustic ceiling is to be installed
to protect the flutter bird from sound
within the restaurant the applicant also
intends to operate limited opening hours
from 5:00 p.m. through to just 11 p.m.
removing the potential for disturbance
into the night and the existing natural
surveillance offered by the retail and
commercial premises during the day will
be extended during the restaurant
opening times especially useful during
the dark winter months there is no
takeaway function proposed finally this
change of use will provide employment
for four staff members and remove a
vacant eyesore from the main street
intervals borne thank you for your time
I was just going to check relive it this
was a boozy shot was it [ __ ] booze
just going on the parking no are you
looking to use Church Street for most of
your parking I've the traffic survey
indicates there is where parking is I
don't think there's any intent to
specifically target certain roads for
car parking I think the the traffic
survey just identified areas when the
restaurant was open where suitable
parking was available 5 to 11 um you
mentioned an acoustic engineer and a
sound level can just give you those
figures again
oh so all noise generating equipment is
located internally and there was a low
fence low speed fan noise of just 32
decibels externally note that this is
much lower than the existing background
noise level
what's the existing background noise
level I don't know it's higher it's very
specific because 30 DB is actually
pretty low I've got the sound report to
hand so I don't know what the thank you
just indicate on page 33
it's Nelson the Parish Council mentioned
about they've got concern about the
windows and doors being shot to ensure
the odors are kept to a minimum and the
system is working efficiently what
what's what's your comments about that
I think that's relating to the kitchen
and obviously the extract system is
extracting from the kitchen cooking
smells
yeah I think so the with regard to the
regime that will also be controlled by
environmental health because of visits
to the premises got the ward member
against the Perry sorry caster Perry I
sit next to him on the side so she'll
certainly begin me digging the ribs a
bit lighter so many apologist about
right
Thank You mr. chairman I'm here wishing
to reinforce the objection I made on
this application
earlier this year principally because
the adverse effect on the residential
immunity of neighbors by Riesz of noise
disturbance and food odors the change of
use to a restaurant from the existing
off-licence premises would become a
nuisance annoyance and caused damage and
inconvenience to the homeowner and
neighbors in Warwick Road there are some
other matters that I wish the members of
the committee also to consider the
homeowner has written confirmation that
change of use to a restaurant facility
would massively restrict the possibility
of anyone obtaining a mortgage finance
on this property
there are also increased fire risks to
the property and therefore increased
insurance premiums in view of having a
restaurant below it the committee should
also note that even if they should grant
if you should grant planning permission
the applicant would have to seek
permission from mr. Yates to proceed
with their plans in accordance with mr.
Yates's lease which clearly states that
mr. Yates property includes all of the
first-floor flat plus all of the
structure up to and including the roof
of the building plus the passage and
yard at the side and rear of the
building including the walls and fences
in other words in order for the
applicant to add to or fix anything
including a flue to the walls of the
first-floor flat he must have permission
an agreement from mr. Yates members of
the committee are reminded that mr.
Yates does not consent to the addition
of either a flu or a chimney I'd also
like to refer to an email that mr. Yates
received from the case officer dated
June the 13th day mr. Yates I referred
to her that the above application and
the ongoing consideration of the scheme
following on from the Planning Committee
January we have had additional
information from the applicant one of
the documents received was the lease
agreement with yourself as the owner of
the property above it would appear that
the applicant has no rights in terms of
attaching the flu to the outside of the
building in terms of planning conditions
we can only oppose though impose those
which are reasonable and which have some
prospect of being achieved
clearly the restaurants would not be
able to operate without the flu and we
would have to recommend a condition
which would prevent the operation of the
restaurant until the flu was installed
even though this is a separate legal
issue if you confirm that you are
unlikely to give permission for the flu
to be attached to the building then I
think the condition would be
unreasonable this would be a new
material consideration in determination
of the application and following
discussion with my managers and the
council's litter solicitor I think we
would change our recommendation on the
application to refusal in other words no
flue or chimney means no restaurant and
therefore no change of views from the
current retail premises I'd also like to
make reference to the access on the
plans which mr. Yates also made
reference to which include another
building in the yard which further
restricts access which is not on the
plans mr. Yates had submitted he did
submit relevant photography which
highlights this fact I have a copy here
and obstructs access to the bins and how
a flue would do the same again no flue
or chimney means no restaurant members
this application is flawed and I urge
you to refuse it
I was just going to ask other places
like there were two pubs yes there are
two pubs serving food we have we have to
take away facilities there's fish and
chips and also Chinese restaurant
as well as China I think it's a focused
on a Chinese takeaway but the king the
king's head and the stag both serve food
sorry counselor yes it's a very large
restaurant coming into well spawn just
off the a four to nine which does take
away and extensive in-house dining I
haven't got the exact number of covers
but it's you mentioned the two pubs on
the to take the two restaurants do they
have ample parking facilities already
the the King's Head has its own carpark
so parking in that part of the village
is not a problem the stag there is
limited parking around Chestnut square
but it's it is pretty limited I would
say the the custom for the stag tends to
be locals who who actually walk to that
facility parking is very very restricted
in well spawn because there is there is
there is no there isn't a lot of
available space
good evening again your objections are
very robust I have to say I'm trying to
it in the evening well spawn has become
a little bit of a dormant tree a doormat
treat village in so much we have a lot
of new housing and a lot of new people
who come and what tends to happen there
is parking available during the daytime
but there is insufficient parking in the
evening which would coincide when the
time of the restaurant would be open the
parking that has been named in Church
Street in Cherry Orchard wearing Mike my
counselor hat I've got big issues with
neighbors wanting to do drop curves and
and increase the parking facility but
it's it's it's it's extremely tight at
the end of the day if you were to grant
Planning Commission for this the
applicant can't go ahead them cap is is
unable to put a flu or a chimney on part
of the building where the lease does not
which is there isn't a time just that
effect on
the counter no is it a blot on landscape
or is it well what what I was going to
mention was that in fact there have been
a number of businesses wanting to come
into the village opticians and a
computer company and they haven't been
able to find retail premises so you know
there are there are are businesses out
there wishing to come into inter well
spawn but the places haven't been made
available to them no I mean that that is
a comment that has been made by a local
retailer directly to me that that there
is a requirement for opt for an optician
to come in to well spawn in the retail
facility and there's also been a
requirement for a computer company but
they haven't been able to find no I
haven't but it's but it is common
knowledge amongst retailers and that
information was given to me by an
existing retailer in bridge Street it
was open it was open quite long long
hours from from the morning because it
served as an off license so it would be
in the evening and during the day
thank you catch the power that's most
kind and apologies again for forgetting
you how could I do that points of
clarification as I was concerned the
wood member and the objective objected
not on planning grounds there were
several grounds which we can't take into
consideration is that the solicitor will
obviously help us with just a quick
reference basically applicants Lister's
basically states that he has a legal
right to access the yard the tenant does
disputed and they really does need as a
committee you should take the applicant
sister's word that he has a right to
implement that permission or to
implement the right and it is a civil
matter I would also refer to condition
for chair there's a Grampian condition
there where it says the restaurant
hereby approved shall not open until the
flu shown on plan such-and-such has been
erected mr. forty functioning so if he
has a right you can erect it if he
doesn't have a right then I'll have to
get consent from the tenant to actually
erect it on to my question where is
thought muse and why should that be a
problem because it by the looks of
things it's some way off and it's it was
raised by third parties and during the
course of a consultation it is I just go
back up to the plan a new development
which is approximately here I understand
this thought Muse is a new development
which I think it was just relating to
parking in general and 50 seconds are
just to protect the wording of the
report
reference
I think it's from search parties just
raising concerns but it is a private
development and the public highway is
just to the north which is the wari Road
yeah
because going back onto parking along
Church Street the Kings head does have
customers who park at the top end there
by the church and it does get very full
at certain times so I can well
understand there is going to be even
though highways don't refer to it a
parking problem for whatever takes place
in the restaurant in terms of the park
and we have had to survey submitted with
the application with the most up-to-date
submitted in April and how a they've got
no objection subject to conditions which
restricts the takeaway which in their
view would be more of the parking and
quickly parking rather than parking and
walking which they'd expect for a
restaurant use and that was their
justification in their comments but the
last time we were not happy when the
parking survey had been doing that's why
we asked Church Street or whatever but
obviously what we have today is an
up-to-date thing that the County Council
approved because that's why we didn't
push you through well not pushing
through but didn't approve it last time
so just to clarify the first survey was
September 2016 and that was Monday the
26th a Tuesday the 27th of September
that that survey was carried out I under
so that the most recent survey submitted
in April was the 3rd 4th 5th which would
Friday Saturday Sunday and Friday the
17th 18th and 19th of March of this year
so that's the difference between the
survey instead of Monday and Tuesday
it's Friday Saturday Sunday for two
weekends over sassed as part of it
though I was correcting
what time of day is that is that all the
hold the weekend is not 24 hours
observation is it just clarify so I
understand the most recent one was
hourly intervals between 5 and 10 that
was a Monday and she's vague survey
sorry and I'll get the next one now so
between 5 and 10 Monday Tuesday back in
September and then for the most recent
one it was hourly intervals again
between half past 4:00 and half past
11:00 on Friday Saturday and Sunday and
on both weekends thank you questions
that mr. yang tries firstly the expired
application in terms of the application
I believe the neighborhood's referring
to it being over the eight-week target
date it's that I'm not sure if that's
correct
so we do have 8 weeks to determine an
application that's the target date we
aim for normally where it goes to
committee we offer an extension of time
so that can be a lengthened process
okay thank you couldn´t thank you but
please share type please thank you and
so in terms of the access we've looked
at highways as part of the application
and mindful it's an existing building as
well so not making any changes to the
shop front the only change is our
internal changes and the flu but the
pictures show some black which parking
area please where you've got go back to
the Federative inches please the other
one the other one that one that is
evidently there's from what I gather
that the mr. Yates parks his van no I
understand there are some photographs
which have appeared on the public
website and if the access is through
this gate here into the application site
in this area here so if I go back to the
site plan it's the access to the side
here and this part because the gates at
the rear of the application site all
deliveries together with his vehicle
that's park they have to go down that
alleyway that's the side access down the
side of the property there's not a grave
Unitron used at home I believe it's
approximately two point one meters
measured down until it widened in this
area here just like to ask our legal
officer to speak about the mortgage that
was mentioned earlier the letter
actually advised by mr. Yates referred
to an independent mortgage advisor and
in the latter he said the food outlet is
granted underneath Stuart's apartment
may not be able to sell or would be able
to force were sorry would be forced to
take a significantly lower price for the
property and the issue I have to that
this is only from my mortgage advisor if
the actual mortgage company provided a
letter saying that we would say
terminate the mortgage if a restaurant
was given permission then there would be
serious issues but this is just from a
mortgage advisor and it shouldn't
basically it's not an issue that this
committee should assess confined to the
bins that were mentioned a number of
times in the investigators presentation
do we have the photographs that he was
referring to just looking down to the
yard again and we can see just in this
area there there's bins there's also
that other building which was made
reference to proposed site plan does
show a possible refuge area here but
there is a condition which is
recommended for a detail to be submitted
and approved so it's worded submission
of a scheme for storage of Refuge so
whilst it's it's there a condition has
recommended for that to come forward and
be approved so with that course access
problems for the for mr. Yates but the
nature of bins he was suggesting was
necessary for a restaurant so it's going
to be more refuse than for a shop he was
suggesting there going to be larger
units with that impact on his access to
her from his parking space and his
property why would today is if something
is which has been recommended as a
condition to be submitted and approved
so that's something we'd be looking to
make sure they're suitably sited and
obviously the sizes then commensurate
with the restaurant use its proposed to
make sure that sufficient storage for
environmental health and so when you're
looking at trying to put that under
condition what what area do you have to
actually work in for that is it just a
small was it to how wide was it two
meters approximately two point white 2.1
meters but then it does widen and to the
rear of the site as you can see up here
but all of the application site is what
we're considering everything in the red
line obviously civil matters access is
something that would need to be agreed
if required and but in terms of the
condition we come back
and that to be submitted and approved
debate yes the brain no chairman I have
a huge amount of sympathy the ward
member the parish council and especially
the leaseholder but looking at the
Fallen heard the highways matter has
been dealt with by highways they say the
parking all the other matters are risen
are conditioned by professionals I'm
looking where I can find a planning
reason for refusal because the matters
were a civil matter a civil matter and
the leaseholder can appalled it and he
won't go ahead anyway whatever decision
we make here but I listen to my
colleagues first before I make a
decision I was on the committee before
they did to be an inconclusive concern
about the traffic surveys that had been
done I think we asked them to go back
and do some more and which they done I
think the shock was open considerable
hours and due to the supermarket in the
village it's obviously you know that's
the fold like other shops I can't see a
reason for a few so there is a legal
problem for establishing the shop so
through an are very very sorry for the
neighbor if you want to put it that way
oh the one one on the top flat and this
building is a bit contrived but in the
respect of finding a reason that would
uphold planning reasons not illegal
I think the problems that we had when we
heard you before have been addressed
when I have concerns about this because
I think that although highways have
passed it I I don't see how they can be
adequate parking for an extra restaurant
given there's already parking issues in
Wales born I'm not convinced by the
condition for the bins because I don't
I'm not quite clear where they go so if
not clear on something then I'm not
convinced by it and also I think that
the level of noise again I'm not
convinced that that would be that
wouldn't be obtrusive and I think
there's much better use for the retail
unit if as councillor Perry said there
are other people I know it hasn't been
put in writing yet there are the people
trying to to use it for retail use that
could be of more benefit there's already
two restaurants and two pubs in quite a
small area and that sort of planning
issue but does that's what I'm sorry can
serve I thought was that I was just
saying the other week we had 17 in
sturdily food I'll go along with what
councillor done almost said having lived
in Church Street Middle East twelve
years ago it was always a fairly
difficult to park there there's always a
lot of noise as much as a survey as
stated it was in the in this early
spring from the sounds of things which
is when people don't really go out to
restaurants and that the summer times
because there's a lot of people go and
park in Church Street and go for walks
into the countryside there and to be
honest with you I think that it's not a
suit at work it's not a suitable place
when they got a lot of other food
outlets or two or three outlets in the
village anyway so I'm not in favor
I think catch the brown is right
come up I don't think are particularly
strong the Highways Authority we've
reversed the two surveys on this and I
come back and done them different times
the highways have actually come back
with the conditions and give their Port
Authority so if we turn it down on
parking grounds
I think we'll be struggling on that one
I think the key point in this is one of
the conditions regarding the
recommendation so condition for yeah
which states that the restaurant hereby
approves are not open till the food
shown on the plan has been erected and
funding publishing them so that's not
agreed the actual restaurant won't won't
open and what the points is that I've
noted that cancer probably mentioned
that there is a possible alternative
uses of the site and from what I can see
if it's not been it's been a valuable
been empty for two years which mr. Olson
said so I think you'll confirm did you
say - yes you're just not yet cants
people just know thank you so I'm on
minding - tends to support the officer
recommendation to grant so have any
proposals or weights there's all windows
and doors to remain closed except for
does that mean that the tenant or the
occupier on the first floor is got a key
to use windows and closed it's not very
not very nice razor you know step it's
the size we can't
yeah and then if it does then it's a
question of enforcement if it's if it's
abused and the court today
well yeah alkanes are going to work
because you indicated if you don't think
we're in a very difficult position as
we're divided if we have a vote we
should know which way we're going and
all second it then as always to accept
to to grant the application all those in
favor recommended to grant resolved to
grant application 16 4/0 1/9 reticle
a mini-break while we all get back so so
if we go back in back into
okay surely you should get back on with
it thank you everybody
so let's move on to our next application
tonight then this is found that is item
six found on page 41 of your agendas
this application reference sent 17 / 0 1
1 1 1 / ful application of well ok
Thank You mr. chairman
full planning permission is sought for
the erection of a one-bedroom detached
dwelling and access on an existing
parcel of land fronting Gillette's Lane
location is shown on the black dot the
application site is a rectangular area
of garden land approximately 13 and a
half meters by 40 meters located on a
private Lane within the village of
brailles you can also see the
neighboring houses Holly walk house to
the west and Stone Croft which is a
grade 2 listed building to the east here
is a recent aerial view of the site and
the private lane showing the application
site outlined in red the plot is
approximately 75 metres from the adopted
highway this slide shows the view across
the site from the southern end the rear
of the plot looking towards Gillette's
Lane the side of Holly walk house can be
seen on the left-hand side of the
picture
this slide shows the view looking to the
rear of the plot this slide shows the
side elevation of Holly walk house with
2 ground floors secondary windows to the
living room which would look towards the
new dwelling
this slide shows the elevations of the
new dwelling the West elevation with no
windows would face Holly walk house and
the East elevation with only two
ground-floor windows would face Stone
Croft which is over 25 meters away this
slide shows the plot layout and the
separation from the neighboring house
the plot is approximately 14 meters wide
where the house is the proposed dwelling
is nine point seven meters wide
resulting in a 2.5 wide space on the
west west side facing Holly walk house
there's one point five meters on the
east side the narrowest point Holly walk
house is approximately one meter from
its own boundary parking and a turning
area are located to the front of the
house the next few slides provide a bit
more context the view looking down
towards Jill its lane with the
application site on the right of the
picture the new access would cut through
the evergreen hedge this is the view
looking up Jill its lane Holly walk
house next door
Apple goth opposite the plot staple hey
slightly further up the lane on the
opposite side and a few more cottages
further up still there have been that's
the end of the presentation there have
been a couple of updates as detailed on
the update sheet due to recently
published housing figures and three
letters have been received from local
residents the recommendation mr.
chairman is to approve the application
for the Reese reasons detailed in the
report thank you
Thank You Alison okay first speak
Rosenthal please from brows parish
council
welcome counselor so you have three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end I'll give you a
warning at the last ten seconds of that
so no thanks
I'm the council met and examined the
site itself from the loan of neighboring
properties earlier on and decided to
object to this because the elevation of
the proposed house such as the relief of
the ground would allow to overlook stone
cross the visited built a listed
building and gaze into itself of bedroom
windows and living dining room as well
as onto conservatory the hedge that
separates them is deciduous and
therefore opaque for only part of the
year it will be hard against as we've
heard Holly walk house and significantly
cut light from the sitting room it has a
chimney which even with adjustments will
belch smoke into the windows of the said
house is on a paddock and lies in the
Cotswolds area of outstanding natural
beauty which means that this will must
receive the highest level of protection
gillich slain a private road as we've
heard and i don't know if this affects
the status of the application as against
a public road is extremely narrow and no
matter what is said there will be real
problems of access i'd like to enlarge
on one or two issues there was a
planning application to build on this
site in 1977 which was turned down and
went to appeal it was turned down his
appeal the inspector said that upper
brailles is a small settlement on
quoting which comprises small clusters
of development and such a development
would it until it seriously impact on
this he considered quote the south side
of Gillis lane does not constitute a
developed frontage and the proposal does
not come within my definition of
infilling unquote and he considered it
to be an undesirable sporadic form of
extension to isolated development and
unacceptable in planning terms this
makes me wonder if criteria have changed
since then maintaining open spaces
implicit in the inspectors of small
clusters of development it is central to
preserving the character of this part of
the Cotswolds AO and be if these spaces
are gone they can't be replaced and we
should all be conscious of a duty of
custodianship
the inspector writes that the
development is of high-quality
architectural design I would dispute
this brailles moreover is already well
ahead in either building or having
permission to build its quota of houses
I believe we're about six and a half
years ahead which means there'll be
plenty of time for the neighborhood
development plan which has identified
various sites to be in place and for any
further building to be complete well
within the timescale consequently it is
no rush the house will overlook
significantly stone Croft caused real
inconvenience to Holly walk house and
Dylan seriously affect the area of
outstanding natural beauty thank you
take questions please from committee
very good evening in in the report about
neighborhood plan this is not included
can you justify swear brailles Parish
Council is with their neighbor the
neighborhood plan yes if you just press
the button so we can thank you it's okay
your brain goes soft it is going through
his final throes and his hat received
one or two glitches recently when
historic England through one or two
expands into the works but once these
have gone I think we're expecting to be
in place within the next nine months yes
counselor fielding there's a attractive
but rather inconvenient we could come
back to
I think the Parish Council states they
think there's going to be overlooking
aspect right any other point any other
questions case caps rose well thank you
very much we go to nick nick horn speak
on behalf of residents please hello yes
mr. horn
welcome you also have three minutes okay
so if you just press them up in the
middle of the microphone and I'll give
you a warning at 10 seconds if that's
okay okay hi I represent the people who
strongly a black tie just planning
application 20 over whom are here
tonight standard builders lorries failed
to get up Gillett slain the road is too
narrow and steep building regulations
fire safety part b5 table 8 states the
road needs to be three point seven
meters wide for a fire appliance
gilaflame varies between two point six
and three point one meters
this means the vehicle would need to be
cited on the be 40 35 which is at least
three times the maximum permitted
hosepipe length of 45 meters from the
proposed property the applicant does not
have the prescriptive right of access to
this plot from the lane it was for
agricultural use and not residential
purposes the proscription Act 1832 is
still very relevant Warwickshire County
Council highways have measured
everything from the main be 40 35 and
have a Nord any issues in Gillis lane
because the status is a private road if
this is the case we as a resonance of
Gillis Lane will refuse permission for
non authorized vehicles to enter the
lane there is no access to this proposed
plot this application is very similar in
many respects to their property Apple
graph planning refusal in 2013 Apple
Garth is directly opposite this proposed
bot it did not meet the core policy c5
9/11 NP PF and Local Plan P R 1 and D
eveyone builders lorries are not going
to be able to turn onto this plot the
turning circle is too great if they
offload on gilaflame they will block the
lane and public footpath to the
detriment using this Lane there is no
disturbance to the level of the verge to
show any access to this plot all
previous banning active allocations and
appeals have been refused to pour this
plot the inspector are submitting on
refusal on appeal includes the plot does
not have developed frontage this shows
there was no access back in 1977 and
there has certainly been no access since
to get explained in 2003 to this
agricultural plot over dominance by
Holly walk house of rear garden amenity
of proposed plot one of the main reasons
for planning refusal apple Garth in 2013
Holly walk house is two east facing
right he's facing lounge windows
overlooking this plot it will severely
restrict the light coming into their
lounge the revised chimney height still
only comes to the top of Holly walk
house bedroom windows curve was causing
severe smoke pollution over dominates
looking into stone trough a great -
listed building in sight of the ancient
monument of Castle Hill unsustainable
development in the village see council
de st. strap and herald august 1/3 2017
we strongly ask you to consider
attending this planning application good
evening I just wonder the the applicant
proposes a red brick or it looks as
though it's a brick can you just tell me
what sort of other buildings or hope of
dwellings are in that Lane and is is
this in accordance as well or is it
natural stone there is a mixture mix
Pali walk houses mixture of brick and
render the house it has some brick but
as you go up it sits all various sizes
there's old old stone houses going back
to the eighteen 1800s okay any other
questions thank you very much thank you
we can move the applicants agent Jane
cash monies
welcome you know six minutes she remain
seating for any questions at the end
over to you I wanted to just use my time
to touch briefly on some of the
objections which had been raised this
evening and during the course of the
application neighbors have said that
there is no need for the house the core
strategy allows for approximately eighty
four houses in brailles and to date
there have been forty-three committed or
built brailles as a category two local
service village and I searched the
principle of a new dwelling within the
built-up area of the village is
acceptable the core strategy allows for
small-scale development within village
confines and proposed single dwelling is
small-scale development the neighborhood
development plan as we've heard is
fairly advanced and has a draft village
boundary the site lies within this
boundary it is in my opinion a natural
info plot on Gillett slain the parish
council earlier this evening referred to
open spaces and the site being important
open space the draft neighborhood
development plan does identify some
important spaces within the village and
this is not one of them looking at other
policies within the emerging
neighborhood development plan policy h2
says that developments on land within
the built-up area boundary 2017 this
site is within that will be supported
where they do not exceed six dwellings
providing they comply with other
policies in the plan and contribute to
housing needs in terms of neighbors the
minimum separation distances to all
nearest neighbors are met and exceeded
the parish council have raised concern
over overlooking two Stone Croft
however only ground-floor side facing
windows are proposed one is a secondary
window to a dining room the other is a
WC both could be obscured if members
feel as
sorry due to the existing hedge between
the two properties I don't believe that
any overlooking would arise the side
facing windows in Holly walk house are
secondary windows to a living room and
that living room is also served by two
larger windows on the front of the
property in terms of design and visual
impact the application proposes a three
by dwelling its scale is modest being
only seven meters too rich councillor
barnes australia about the height and
the on the submitted plans you can see
the North elevation shows the
neighboring Holly walk house walk which
will be at a higher level the overall
width of the proposed house is just over
nine point five meters wide and the
overall plot is or almost 14 meters wide
the plot is 40 meters deep the lane is
characterized by various designs and
sizes of properties some plots are
deeper and narrower whilst others are
shallower and wider there are examples
of smaller plots within close proximity
to the application site including
Weaver's cottage just further up the
Lane the size of the house does not
dominate the size of the plot and
overall the dwelling is not out of
keeping with what is a fairly mixed
pattern of development in the area and
would not harm the wider a OMB Gillett
Slane is a private road work she County
Council have fully assessed the
application and conclude that visibility
is satisfactory and that there would be
no highways danger either on Gillett
slain or elsewhere the Parish Council
have raised concerns about construction
traffic and the planner has proposed a
construction management plan condition
which is appropriate for a site such as
this you'll note that the applicant also
owns land to the rear which is in the
blue line and this has an access off the
B 403 v this could possibly be used as a
construction access if necessary I'm not
saying that's definitely the case but
it's it's an option out there the parish
have also commented on the chimney and
we've submitted amended plans during the
course of the application to ensure it
meets Building Regulations an earlier
speaker mentioned an application
opposite that
Garth which was an outline application I
think in 2013 for a single dwelling that
was determined in a different policy era
to what we're now working in and that
site was half the size of the
application site which is before you
this evening there are no objections
from any consul T including highways
public rights-of-way seven Trent and
ecology I hope that you will agree that
this is a sensible proposal for a modest
dwelling on a natural info plot within
the local service village of brailles
thank you for listening thank you any
questions please councillor Barnes yes
so the current is bounding Gillett Lane
is currently a hedgerow on to the
application site so there is no existing
vehicle access into the site it has been
used in the recent past for a period of
approximately ten years as garden land
associated with Holly walk house I'm
gonna have to ask members of the public
to stop interjecting please it's
distracting and it wasn't done during
other people's time to speak so thank
you yes would you would you repeat that
please
so my understanding is that parcel of
land has been rented to the owners of
Holly walk house as garden land and it's
being used by them for a period of
approximately ten years as garden land
Perry thank you good evening Jane um
could you just comment on the position
and location of the chimney being that
the property is slightly lower than its
neighboring property with regard to the
escape of smoke and fumes and that type
of thing because of its lowered position
I'm certainly not an expert in building
regulations but the parish council
raised concern in their initial comments
about the height of the chimney and the
slope of the roof which it's next to all
the proposed dwelling and under building
regulations I think there has to be and
Alison will correct me if I'm wrong but
I think there needs to be one point at
least one point five meters between that
the bottom of the ridge and the top of
the chimney so the height of the chimney
has been increased to ensure it meets
building regulations in terms of smoke
and emissions can I just come come back
with a supplementary but it can or it it
could be a matter for clarification I'm
I'm more concerned about the escape of
smoke to the neighboring building rather
than necessarily how it sits on the
current dwelling that's proposed in
front of it I have to be honest I'm not
an expert on that
yes counsel fielding coming in
indicating that there is no access to
the plant yes I don't know if there is a
the the location plan which has the red
and blue lines which we submitted but
the application site as as shown there
so at the moment there is no existing
vehicle access that that site is bounded
to get its lane to the north with a
hedgerow now I don't know if the case
officer does have the blue line plan but
if you see their Stone Croft
to the east and then there's a building
to the south you can see a little narrow
gap
there we are so the orientation slightly
changed there but you can see the plot
and then can you see the blue lines
so in effect accessing off the B 403 5
there is an access that that point there
now that isn't proposed to be used to
serve the dwelling the new vehicle
access for the dwelling is to be off til
it's Lane as shown on the plan but what
I was saying is it could be used in
relation to construction traffic if that
was deemed necessary the proposed
vehicle access to serve the dwelling is
up as up Gillett Sloane we're not
proposing it as the this is simply a
suggestion if there is a if the
construction needs to but the applicant
doesn't own units Lane its private Lane
so it's owned by a number of properties
so there is no control that the
applicant has to widen it in any way but
what I would say is worksheet County
Council highways have assessed it not
just the public highway network but they
have also considered the impact on good
its Lane and haven't raised an objection
bonds the axis for the new house could
go on this very narrow narrow line but
because the narrow
so narrow that construction shop it will
go down the blue line the proposed
vehicle access for the new house so for
new residents would be up Gillett slain
that is where the construction traffic
could go but equally there is an
alternative if necessary on the blue
land if that's considered appropriate
okay no further questions thank you very
much okay points of clarification once
again yes counselor brain Patrol access
along this narrow line and we'll the
entrance to this depends what the
resolution is with the construction
management plan presumably something we
condition I think it's maybe ten houses
including the two of the bottom which
actually face onto ok council fielding
we'll give a turning circle for any
vehicle or access building is this a
question the new access to the
properties would involve taking out a
small section of the rocking of the
evergreen hedge at the front to the
public again to refrain from making car
noises thank you but I've included a
recommendation for a landscaping
condition because obviously when you
remove part of a hedgerow or whether
it's an evergreen hydro or a native
hedgerow some sort of mitigation is
required as far as I understand that has
been used as Garland for approximately
ten years when I was out on site I could
see that towards the front of the plot
that have been allotments like like
vegetable plots had been marked out and
used as vegetable plots and it looked
like domestic garden and it was accessed
I walked into the into the plot from the
neighboring house Holly walk house Harry
yes I've got two questions really a
about smoke from the chimney which
because of the property is below the
level of its neighboring property I'm
concern about the smoke coming into the
neighboring property if you can give me
some unsnap and then I'll come back on
my other question when this was
originally raised by the parish council
I took the application around to
Building Control had quite a long
discussion with them and it resulted in
some amended plans being submitted
which which increase the height of the
chimney building control are happy with
the revised proposals
my other question revolves around the
setting of the to grade listed buildings
have you got some pictures that show
their actual setting because they they
seem to form sort of a bit of a gateway
or that you have you got a picture of
them in their setting rather than just
the building itself because that
so stone craft is the this listed
building its it faces the main road here
separating the two plots along this
boundary is a four meter high beach
hedge which although it is part
deciduous it's it's very mature and very
substantial and it although it is
deciduous Beach is characterized because
it's it retains some of its leaves in in
the winter so it's thoughts being kind
of partially deciduous and it's quite
often used by developers because it does
retain quite a lot of foliage in through
the winter so I don't I didn't feel that
there was very much relationship between
stone craft and the plot itself 43 yes
counsel bones do you appreciate their
edge got a command but my concern if the
house was built is actually the house
next door is very large in that little
road totally different
I appreciate what they're saying in the
respective highways aren't objecting to
it I would have preferred a bigger as
developed instead of seven meters I well
laugh as you might but there is
obviously concerned applicant expanded
way round DTP ilanic by across the field
which I think would be approved reactors
cancer brain sorry
all these days along Lane obviously been
built at some stage and that
construction traffic so the highways a
reasonable in their assessment to offer
no objection so just nipping back for a
point of clarification and can you help
us with that one within in terms of the
developing neighborhood plan is this
area but it's not identified as yes pick
up on that is that also is it within the
housing mix has been required as well by
the village and no point of
clarification sorry so is it three beds
and tips
yes Sonia it's a fairly modest
three-bedroom house Calipari okay I'm
gonna go get some of my colleagues views
cuz I actually think it's got a I feel
it does impact on the character and the
setting of the grade ii listed dwellings
in that lane I feel it's out of
character because it's to me it's like
an estate house suddenly plunked in the
middle of a lane of rather individual
properties and therefore I feel it's
design is is not in keeping with other
properties in the lane and I for me
because you've got the two great listed
buildings there there's a sense of space
around each one and I just think it's
not quite in the right place so in terms
of out of character impact on the grade
2 listed buildings I'm going to go
against the officers recommendation on
this one whilst its meeting a
neighborhood plan requirement of being
three bed I concur with councillor
fielding and councillor Perry regarding
it just not being in the right place I'm
not convinced that the beach boundary
defense with the beech trees is
significant enough to to actually reduce
the impact this new new build would have
and I'm also not convinced about the
chimney and the impact that will have so
I again with the game against
recommendation
there's been quality points my advice
salt don't think the planning objections
are strongly enough to two against
recommendation it's an open space but
not identified as a special one it's
part of the neighborhood area principle
boundary principle visibility is okay
the console tees have not particularly
compliant with perhaps lock to see the
construction management plan
strengthened include the proposal this
point is that something you would
propose council with those conditions
added so the obscure blazing and and
strengthen the construction plans you
say yes can we require that the access
for construction traffic will be
directly off the before 0:35 as in going
through the access land condition noted
as a request that we will be making
we're not gonna second her at this point
oh yes counselor brain come speak I
don't think we've real strong reason to
have a secondary access
actually I hear what you say and if it's
necessary then the note would probably
pretty young that I would just draw my
colleagues attention to page 48 which
the impact on hurry to the actual assets
listed buildings that says there's no
harm to listed buildings and his four
paragraphs from that statutory Council
to us one to draw that to the attention
of the committee thank you I think
counsel Brian said he was happy for it
to go in as a note regarding yes do we
need a seconder for this of course
councilor brain after second which I
think I agree with counts the Cramton
council brain which is that there's
there's no reason we need proper
planning reasons to refuse this I'm not
seeing them coming up here and I'm
reminded of something that often
councilor ban says which is how how
villages do evolve over time
you know villages do evolve you have
different styles of answers and you have
different types of house being built
over a period of time so that's my
thinking should we go to the vote all
those then in favor of granting please
with the additional comments and notes
please show committee therefore resolves
to grant application reference 17/2 0 1
1 1 1 / Fu help and we can move to the
next item on tonight's agenda
right item seven this is application
reference 17 / 0 1 3 8 9 / ful and
slammed off Priory Lane Billiton priors
and is the direction a single dwelling
was associated landscaping presenting
officer Darren Wilson over to you
Thank You chairman the application site
lie to the north of peloton fliers as
identified by the plaque draw on this
plan
Hilton priors is identified as a
category four local service village with
an uncounseled core strategy the
application site is outlined in red and
has the existing particular access to
the south east on to Priory Lane in this
location here to the use of the site
lies a public footpath SS 8c which is
shown by the green dashed line on this
plan Millfield farmhouse is a grade 2
listed building which size to the south
of the site as identified in red to the
east south and west of the site lied
dwellings and their associated gardens
and to the north paddock land which
extends eastward hon information is
sought for the erection of a detached
2-story dwelling and associated flat
roof garage
this slide shows on a historic satellite
image militant friars and the
surrounding countryside the application
site is outlined in red fiery Lane is
also visible on this slide which is a
single width Lane access which descends
down to the main road you can see just
down this way this slide shows the
proposed site plan which identifies a
location of the dwelling and its
associated detached garage dwelling is L
shaped in form with this really
single-story projection which sex tends
to the north the dwelling is proposed to
be served by a figler access from Priory
lane to the south east of the
application site proposed parking
associated with the dwelling is shown to
the south of the site with a garden area
located to the north a stone wall is
also proposed adjacent to the
single-story element the application
sites Lakes westwards as shown by the
contours on this plan the closest
neighbors are also available to the east
and south of the site shown here the
black unto the south with respect to
drainage the site lies within flood zone
1 and does not fall within an area of
drainage concern this slide shows the
proposed elevations of the dwelling and
detached garage proposed dwelling would
be two storey in height with a pitch
roof and would include a single-story
rear flat roof projection repose which
height of the dwelling is 8 meters
approximately with a new site of
approximately 4.6 meter
we're post-wedding a simple in design
with a number of larger openings the
carriage and the dwelling proposed to be
finished in vertical timber cladding
with zinc and cedar on reefs
respectively a line of stone walls
proposed alongside the single-story
projection as shown on the East
elevation so this one is a section and
you can see the wall extending along
here the single-story projection which
goes to the north this slide identifies
who proposed floor plans but first floor
four bedrooms are proposed with
associated bathrooms at ground floor the
dwelling would be open plan with living
space dining space and kitchen a
separate utility room and boot room are
also proposed so ground floor the
separate rooms there and the garage to
the south this photograph is taken from
friary lane looking towards the existing
field access of the application site
which is just you can see that the
trailer here just about here parking for
neighbors is also shown so detonated
spaces before here and one just here
this photograph was taken from within
the application site looking east
towards a neighboring dwellings one and
two Priory bungalows but you can see
here with their garden areas just to the
rear this photograph is taken from
within the application site looking
southwards towards two Priory Lane which
is visible in the distance this image
also identifies a change in ground
levels across the site which slopes
westwards towards the right of the image
so change and ground levels going this
way this photograph was taken from the
public footpath SS 8c looking towards
the application site other dwellings
which lie along cross brick row are
visible within this image so those are
the other drownings in the application
sites approximately over here this
photograph is taken from the public
footpath in the adjacent paddock looking
back towards the application site in a
similar direction the proposed dwellings
which live prospector our visible within
the image as this existing field
boundary of vegetation so those are the
dwellings and the application sites
approximately over here this flight
identified a number of dwellings which
lie within close proximity of the
applications like just to give a bit
more context so this is the application
site you've got the dwellings over here
over here and down Priory relay other
properties that are available the two
short videos which I've taken from
within the application site which I'll
now look to play so it's video one
within the application site move around
one and two Priory been glazed so here
as you can see there's quite a lot of
vegetation on the site at the moment
neighboring dwellings in the parking
space approximately here but the access
proposed in this southeast corner to
Priory lanes there as well and the
existing vegetation to the side of the
site just moving background and the
second video again is from within the
application site just moving around just
to give it a better understanding of how
it relates and as it goes around you'll
see the paddock which is in the
applicants ownership extending eastwards
of public footpaths
up here on this higher level an existing
boundary treatment which you could see
in the earlier photograph there are a
number of updates which have been
circulated on the update sheet yeah the
recommendations to grant an information
subjects with conditions and notes
outlined on pages 69 and 70 70 of the
committee agenda thank you thank you
right on to our first speaker councillor
green all pleas from pollutant prize
Parish Council welcome you have three
minutes you remain seated for any
questions at the end
over to you Philip Roth Parish Council
has four main objections to this
application reason one our neighbourhood
plan research showed this site is an
area that our residents did not want to
be developed the landscape sensitivity
study carried out as part of the core
strategy states this particles not
considered appropriate for housing
development and designates it as
pastoral round which are has been for
the last 80 years
other sites were considered appropriate
and an outline application has been
approved for ten properties on one of
those
reason to policy CS 15 states that
development will not be allowed out
area boundary of a local service village
this whole product is outside the
boundaries submitted by the SDC policy
team and approved by the parish council
permitting new developments outside the
agreed built very boundary sets a
dangerous precedent as well as bearing
contrary to the core strategy reason 3
the latest plans are planting to what
was originally the access road on the
three dwelling application this would
totally landlocked the remainder of the
public so access to mobile maintain the
sewers or overhead power lines would be
impossible if you visit the site and
you'll see on the videos you will see
how poorly it has been maintained and
even the well used for public footpath
is overgrown the reason for policy cs5
states that development will take place
in a manner that minimizes and mitigates
its impact district council have
consistently been against development in
this location in his written statement
to the planning inspector the District
Council raised its concerns on the
impact to nearby dwellings especially
numbers one and two priority bungalows
which has small social housing
properties saying due to the limited
size of these plots and their
orientation to the appeal site the
district Planning Authority considers
that the proposed development would have
a harmful overbearing impact to the
amenity of these properties the planning
officer persuaded the applicant to
withdraw their previous single dwelling
application she stated she was concerned
in size height and design would not
reflect the dwellings within the
locality of the site and that it would
have harmful impact apart from the
priority bungalows this proposal will
have a significant negative impact by
reason of loss of privacy and
overshadowing on the private amenities a
number two primary line on the
properties on Kyneton Road a popular
slightly lower height and a shortened
garden nothing has changed with 19
proposed conditions and 17 letters of
rejection this is not a straightforward
application we urge you to refuse it as
it contravenes policies 5 9 and 15
amongst others as policy 16 be for 2,000
homes has been met 14 years
it's time to protect the local service
villages thank you thank you any
questions
sir Perry good evening I just wonder
whether you could advise whether there
are any other dwellings in the village
that particularly reflect the timber
cladding that is being proposed on this
application the village has a mixture of
designs I think where there is a
agricultural barn just up the line which
is any other questions
that case Council thank you very much we
can get a miss - mr. Jagan please okay
you also have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end over to you
yeah I'm at number two prior in the
house which was shown in the videos next
to the plot this is planning with pretty
much the same design throughout with
minor modifications recently a design
and the setting which I think your
committee and the inspector rejected
it's had no support from anyone other
than the applicants and their advisors
and my colleague has mentioned the
officer u-turn when in April when
application was withdrawal and she said
in no uncertain terms the dwelling by
reason of size height and design would
not reflect the dwellings within the
locality and would introduce harm to the
character of the area contrary to CS 9
in a s10 therefore with the greatest
respect she has gone 180 degrees in the
space of less than six months on what is
pretty much the same design from a
reduction in height of the garage that
seems to me unsustainable I would say
that the village has been somewhat
bypassed
again by private discussions which have
taken place to bring this application to
where it is which I think have slightly
hindered our ability to respond to it
you don't need me to remind you of the
cap on local service villages category
for Billiton prize is somewhat unlucky
to be even in category 4 with very very
limited facilities there is a very small
shop at the garage there is a limited
bus service and there is a village hall
therefore in terms of sustainability
it's very difficult to make the case how
this house will justify what will
provide better for the village or indeed
the wider area the officer has commented
on the waiting of the plan which defines
the boundary of the village which has
been consulted the report suggests that
it hasn't has been extensively consulted
in the village it may not have been
consulted wider within the district and
Council and the village is very clear on
that on that sir boundary plan which
excludes this site the inspector also
commented on the fact of the harm in his
opinion outweighed the benefits in terms
of amenity privacy outlook peace and
quiet for the neighboring properties
including mine there will be a
significant problem with parking which
the plans showed the parking space is
fully taken there is informal partic
parking as there is one in more places
which will immediately be a problem as
soon as this scheme takes out something
like three spaces ten directions there
also the public footpath context
drainage issues and biomass boilers
which will produce large hoppers for the
pellets summary it's a market led scheme
without housing need outside three core
policies it's the wrong thing to stop
you there's no long place thank you
thank you okay any questions please yes
counselor brain number two so looking at
the site location plan as you come down
Priory Lane
the last detached house next to the plot
the parking is all for the Orbitz social
housing which is behind from mr. picture
behind here there are three cottages
into one two bungalows and there is
considerably more parking than that
there in an evening of an evening yeah
if you look in the corner there you see
the silver car because of highway
requirements turning circles and that
land where the silver car is actually
owned by the owner of the site that will
in effect take out three spaces thank
you hey further questions its jagged
thank you very much okay we can get the
applicants agent with Goodall please
welcome so you still have six minutes
which is a combination the previous two
speakers time thank you
if you'd remain seated for any questions
at the end the the two gentlemen before
me have supersedes this application for
three dwellings the inspectors comments
were primarily focused on the
application whole but more specifically
for the two larger dwellings which has
admitted those two larger dwellings were
started on
the past and that kind of wrapped around
and behind the orbits so for housing
weddings and we're considerably larger
nevertheless we've taken on board the
comments that were made and we've
actually made this application smaller
still then it was previously one of the
other items of clarification the the car
parking spaces that are being referred
to the five designators lied to the
right hand side there are there is own
designated space to the guarded spaces
the application this evening is
primarily due to the objections raised
by the parish council member
the application has received no other
technical objections and is deemed to
satisfy policy as outlined by the report
the quantities that respond to include
ecology public rights-of-way highways
the parish
the inspector in particular this
thank you any questions from acquittee
canceled bonds I wondered if I could
have the original picture of with the
village because to be on now the picture
we had before I was out of the village
man but that looks very sort of in the
village boundaries the my
that picture there looks different I
could just draw your attention to the
update sheet as well which clarifies the
issue a little further as well okay any
further questions no okay thank you very
much yes we go to the ward member now
please counts low tunnel welcome
counselor you have five minutes yes I
believe the parish counts was actually
asked if this wee part of the
presentation
thank you sure Thank You committee um so
obviously this is the third application
this one with 19 conditions and 19
letters of objection I understand from
the update sheet that has been to
further letters which for a small sls v4
is a marked level of local feeling
regarding its development and rightly so
the residents of penitent prized feel
they are simply not being listened to
must remember there's a human cost to
parsing applications such as this for
the residents of the orbit houses and
bungalows who are both elderly and some
of them disabled and the primary
bungalows that have been mentioned that
you've seen in the video are occupied by
two elderly gentlemen one who's disabled
and one who struggles with anxiety now
at the last minute we found out that
there is very little weight attached to
the built-up area boundary but I do
think it is of note to discuss it put it
in prize are fully engaged with SDC
planning policy team to decide upon the
boundary for its built-up area boundary
like it can clearly be seen from the
diagrams that this land falls outside
the built-up area boundary and it is of
note that this built-up area boundary
was finalized or we thought had been
finalized in July this year and this was
not available to the inspector
so his off-the-cuff remark about
this plot we've been within the village
boundary we questioned and the built-up
area boundary is to distinguish land
within boundaries where new developments
are acceptable imprint support from land
outside the boundary
we're subject certain exemptions
development is not acceptable and to
pass an application outside this
boundary shouts of inconsistency in
policy which is concerning and also
confusing because surely a boundary even
if it hasn't yet been fully adopted dis
been advised is a boundary the committee
should also know that this land has been
designated as pastoral land for the past
80 years and Milan sensitivity study
carried out as part the core strategy
was not seen as suitable for development
the residents fully engaged in locating
other sites there is an outline planning
for 10 homes of one two and three bed
unit on a ribbon development on the
boundary road in the SDC's meeting
housing needs document it states that
it's now recognised that the old
top-down model of planning whereby
housing developments we're in were in
effect imposed on local communities by
local authorities or developers is
neither appropriate or sustainable and
it feels as if that is what is happening
here in their neighbourhood plan
research the residents stated they did
not want this site to be developed
now with the granted neighborhood
planning the council is committed to
giving local people the opportunity to
influence where homes are built in their
communities and encourage parish
councils to carry out and prepare for
neighbourhood plans and it seems if
we're simply ignoring this with this
application paragraph 187 in the NPP F 3
decision-making
it states that local planning authority
should work proactively with applicants
to secure developments that improve the
economic and social environment of the
area and I don't believe this does so it
seems as if this type of District
Council simply isn't listening to the
residents this development does not fit
with the housing mix of Curtin priors
and NPP F section 6 paragraph 50 talks
for wide choice of high-quality homes
local planning authority should identify
the size type and tenure and range of
housing that is required in particular
locations reflecting local demand and
this does not do so this is not
sustainable development you rely on the
private car because the bus service is
infrequent
there are no local amenities there's no
school and as a small store attached to
a local garage cs9 talks about proposals
being sensitive to the setting and
existing build form and whilst I respect
that the previous application was for
three buildings
the inspector noted many things about
the actual application and he noted that
the development would harm the living
conditions of occupiers of neighboring
properties particularly prairie
bungalows he also noted that the
introduction of vehicle movements close
to the rear elevations of the gardens of
numbers 1 & 2 prairie bungalows were
required to living environment could
reasonably expected would have an
adverse effect on the living conditions
and occupier to these properties as both
the elderly and disabled gentlemen the
inspector also noted that because this
is visible from the public footpath and
regardless of acceptable distances
between the house and prairie bungalows
it will destroy the view from prairie
bungalow and block them in that users of
the public footpaths a sensitive
receptors to change and the effect of
development would introduce an increased
sense of enclosure when walking to and
from the larger expanses of open
countryside to the north he also noted
that the localized impact of the
development on the character on the
character and sight and setting of
pollutant price village would be
significant when considering planning
balance the inspector concluded that the
proposal would conflict with the
approach and location and supply of
housing in policies cs 15 and a s 10 and
the approach to character and appearance
including landscape character design and
local distinctiveness in policy cs5 cs4
and cs5 teen the pollock the proposal
there who would not be in accordance to
the development plan it is a note that
the developer has not engaged the locals
bulking is an issue after 4 o'clock it
becomes problematic you saw on a
photograph that there will be M
allocated space for taking there's a lot
of informal parking as well ten seconds
it just feels as if you keep on knocking
they'll finally pass the application
with this one I urge you not to support
the officers recommendation council
fielding is part of
can I just ask you to press the button
the neighborhood plan hasn't been
finalized is my understanding it's just
it's currently and they've done the
research for it and they are having
assistance from a Warwickshire rural
committee plans to help them with a
neighbourhood plan but they've done the
research for it can you just confirm in
this I've missed it when the last local
housing needs survey was carried out by
the parish and if so was the housing
requirement to ask them the ward member
for later clarification can slip-ons
but we had an application on the village
boundary we believe it's the red land
can I come back on that that was done
with full um liaison with the residents
than the locals so that was selected by
the surprise there any further questions
okay the councillor Donal thank you
right points of clarification yes
counselor fielding and the question is
as
having a sassy application officers
consider that it does Ford in the
physical confines of the village
reference was made to an appeal decision
which officers have given significant
weight within the assessment I have got
the plans sorry I'm just scanning
through this was the application that
went to appeal for three dwellings so
one two three
this was plot three which is similar to
the application slide we're considering
now
with this garden space here and then the
two two to the north and the public
footpath goes through the sites over in
this location here as part of that
assessment the inspector made some
comments about whether or not it would
be within the physical confines of the
village and in his view he considered
that the plot that we're looking at here
so in this area would fall within an
infill in in their view and that's what
officers have given significant weight
but it is a paddock and it's a paddock
which extends up round and then it joins
open fields to the north any other
points of clarification councillor Perry
thank you happy across any data on the
local housing needs survey that the
parish might have undertaken that you
would have considered as in terms of
preparing this committee report in terms
of in terms of housing needs survey I'm
not aware of one that's published in
relation to this settlement and so
normally the parish council has one
commissioned there's nothing available
in our councils website with respect to
pilot empires okay okay go to the debate
who would like to celebrate difficult
one again to go against the inspector
when he says it's in the physical
confines of the village it's difficult
because if he did go to appeal I fear
that we would lose again or not lose
again but he would be acceptable but I
do feel for the people who live in the
bungalows and the parking area but
there's no real reasons for refusing in
my view but I listen to my colleagues at
the end
so think of some planning policy anyone
else like to speak in the debate council
bonds no I would have liked this
application and the last application
yeah
because as far as I can see if there is
size book and math to the joining
properties is too great I can see there
it is really in the village boundary
although it isn't or whatever it's
adjoining properties but the songs
baulkham at to look like a bomb down the
road is the only thing that I'm
concerned about
Thank You councillor fielding surely the
shop should be included within the
boundary of what is the parish service
village it's more a policy question
there's a particular application but
it's fair point
attended we've had previous applications
of previous committees where information
from planning inspectors was considered
to trump various different arguments for
want of a better phrase and we've got
quite a strong steer from the plan
inspector that it is in the built up
area and with the update sheet as well
saying the level of white afforded to
the draft built up area boundary
document has been revised to no white
it's I think it's clear that the plan
respect his opinion is the material
planning decision that we seem to be
saying well is it or isn't it I know the
ward member actually I think I've wrote
it down mentioned an off-the-cuff
comment
so whether that's that's for I think
it's it will be in the actual planning
report back from the planning inspectors
are words I would habit Arial white
obviously concerned about the landscape
sensitivity access to public paddock and
things to do with it being the pastoral
and variety for a year so I can see a
lot of emotive reasons but I'll be
coming up with significant planning
reasons to refuse this and I'm
struggling to say the least
calipari thank you
this application doesn't sit very well
with me I'm afraid I've got a concern
about its design including bulk just
feel it see it its bulk will have a
great effect on the development and
character of its local amenity I think
there's adverse effect on the
residential amenity of the neighbors
visual impact the development feel it's
in terms of dwellings it may have been
designed to look like an agricultural
barn but it's out of character in terms
of its neighboring dwelling so I fill
those in there's a visual impact to the
development there's design including the
Vulcan massing and I've got three
material
well unless we have no proposal it was a
mixture the village was a mixture of
types of buildings there wasn't a
particular character that was identified
so I just wanted hey Lee can we say it's
out of character if there's that one
that so that's what I wouldn't you know
that's where I'll be you know we
obviously we've been disagreed we were
split on the previous one so it all is
subjective so I was okay I think for me
I'm gonna have to say I agree with the
officers recommendation here I think
that you know the main thrust of people
arguing against this is whether or not
this is been in the boundary in the
built up boundary of the village and I
think we've got a steer although I'm
conscious that I would never take what
the the plan inspectors said on a
different application you know as being
gospel for this application I think
there's at least here here so telling us
broadly speaking what they think or what
planning inspector would think in terms
of the build up boundary and I think it
sort of echoes my own thoughts as well
in terms of the built up boundary here
with that in mind I'm happy to propose
the committee grants the application do
I have a seconder second do you want to
continue the debate or we can tend to go
to vote don't okay let's get though the
proposal istagram to this application
all those in favor please show against
and one abstention
therefore the committee votes to
resolves to grant application reference
17 / 0 1 3 8 9 / ful and we can move to
item 8 on the agenda
right that's our final application for
the evening item 8 found on page 73 so
this is application reference 16 / 0 1 2
1 3 2 5 / ful its fill out the lamb to
the rear of White Hart public house
Stratford Road new Bolden's tower this
description of the development is for
the construction of three dwellings and
the reconfiguration of the carpark and
access to serve the public house
presenting officers Aaron Winston again
there over to you
thank you to the application site lie to
the east of new ball Don style
settlement set to the east of a
Stratford Road the a for 300 as
identified by the black dot on this plan
new ball Tom style is identified as a
category three local service village
then the council's adopted core strategy
site also lies within the Fairview
Bertram control designation this slide
identifies the application site outlined
in red the application site includes the
White Hart public house and its
associated car park and other land
within its curtilage the science
enclosed by roads on all sides including
strapped a row to the West Chapel Lane
to the north and to the east and to the
south lies rookery Lane accessed from
Chapel Lane is one way in a clockwise
direction to these of the site lies Park
View farmhouse which is great - listed
building identified in red on the plan
just over here plan information is
sought for the erection of three
dwellings including a detached dwelling
and a pair of semi-detached dwellings
this slide shows a proposed site plan
for the development access the public
house has retained from a Stratford Road
with car parking spaces identify the
thirty-five thirty-four cars including
one Blue Badge space which is this one
here plots for you would be accessed
from Chapel Lane to the east of the site
and plots one into you from Wickery Lane
to the south proposed dwellings would be
separated from the public house and its
associated curtilage by 2 meter hi brick
boundary wall parking for each dwelling
is located on private driveways and
garden areas repose to the rear inside
of each of the dwellings respectively to
the southeast corner of the application
site a number of conifer trees are
proposed to be removed to accommodate
the development don't know if you can
see it we can see the outline of the
trees here and here
this slide shows a proposed floor plans
and elevations of the three dwellings
and their associated garages each
dwelling would have accommodation set
over two floors including living space
at ground floor and four bedrooms at
first floor within each unit the
proposed dwelling seek to be finished
predominate in stone with some smaller
areas proposed to be in brick design
features include pitch rubes gable
features chimneys and canopy details you
can see here
the detached property
this one and then the pair of
semi-detached ground-floor you can see
the separation here and here so that's
one unit and a unit to the side this
photograph has taken from a Stratford
Road looking towards the application
site the White Hart public house is
visible in the forefront of the image to
the left of the existing car park lies
Chapel they just just here
this photograph was taken from the
Stratford Road looking northwards
towards the application sites rickly
Lane is visible to the right of the
image just here this slide shows a
number of photographs taken within close
proximity to the application site to
provide a greater context of the
character of the area experience so
along the Stratford Road here down with
curry lane and again along Chapel Lane
here this photograph shows - it is of
Park View farmhouse the close heritage
asset both photographs are taken from
within the application site so one 15
car park on one closer to the d'Alene
this slide shows Chaplin Arikara Lane
moving from the top right image to the
top left down to the bottom right and
then to the bottom left reflects a
clockwise direction of travel around the
application site using these lanes the
bottom left image also identifies a
change in ground level from the lane to
the application site which is
approximately not point 7 - not point
eight meters as you move along as you
can see just along this section here
there are two short videos which I'll
now show you taken from within the
application site moving around from
refree lane you can see the existing
access into the public house car park on
the open space this is the application
site where the planes were proposed and
the trees to be removed here moving
background and there's Chapel Lane there
just to give you a context in the second
video just a short one moving towards
the list of buildings to the left across
the site trees to be removed the rear of
the perb an existing car parking and the
existing trees just moving background
now to Chapel Lane you can see a number
of the neighbors in the distance and
then the grade 2 listed building is just
here
we move background it's garden in this
location you can see the change of
ground levels as well approximately on
that video but a number of updates which
have been circulated within the update
sheet the recommendation is to grant an
information to subject to the conditions
and notes outlined on page 81 at the
committee agenda and within the update
sheet thank you
Thank You Aaron our first speaker
councillor Stephen unit pleased
Reddington parish council hello welcome
thank you for waiting so you have three
minutes if you remain seated for any
questions at the end
thank you Trenton Perrin CalPERS council
object jeff the proposed rule does not
identify or address any local housing
need new ball dance tower already has
permission for 95 new properties already
which is well above its numbers for LSP
three village and it's already the
excessive allocation of new homes and
village and out of the instructors
course reserve so they were living on
the white house and there's another
thing that we had the developers never
come and spoke to any of the parish
council regarding its development but we
believed that the open green space to
the rare could have been used as
potential to improve the the immunity of
offers to more families at the moment it
has no enclosed area for families and
does not gather that trade it should
also be noted that this is a small
although it is a small development new
baldon downstairs already had eight
houses in total of small developments of
ones twos and fives and this will make
it 11 and if we carry on at this rate by
the end of the core strategy period of
twenty thirty one we're probably going
to be around about another thirty odd
houses
we emphasize again neva already has
relative of his fair share development
as a nice recaps reads at no point as I
said before as a developer come to speak
to us about this and we think we could
have supported in the development I
think if you read our initial objection
we said that we will be happy to support
two properties in this area
and we also have concerns as of the
access free chapel lane for the detached
development in the left-hand corner that
as I'm looking at it because that is a
single carriageway around and that is
the only way to get to that one property
any questions please parish council yes
counselor Trump want houses to be built
in your parish how far is that we don't
have a planner moment we are at the
point again three one that we've been
hit in the last few years with the
development part that has been approved
235 became three and the development of
52 so we were more concerned at the the
numbers our village has been hit by and
the community more concerns about the
numbers our village has been hit by so
even with those developments already in
place and been approved and also the
small development if we Karen up this
rate of approving we'll have
approximately probably a hundred and
twenty odd extra houses in a village of
any two hundred forty council brain but
knowing the four decades it is enough
the reason why we were support
you know to developments because we
thought that if they had comes back to
us which said can you develop the green
space to be more secure for families to
go and enjoy the outside next the other
one was closed down a few years ago and
developed into five yes good evening
thank you for waiting
um just welcome your views on in in
terms of the character of the proposed
development because it's taking place
right in the center of the village which
is surrounded by older properties just
wondered what the parish council thought
about potentially urbanizing this
particular section of the village we
looked under the view there are some new
properties opposite this development
which have been developed we know that
Cotswold stone sort of style so there
are there are newer properties in the
area as well it was more we didn't want
to lose all the open space so we don't
want to just enclose the village say
you've got nothing left in the middle
it's nice to have these open green
spaces council bonds it says but it's
not probably not the most safest because
the children have to go through the car
park we've all wanted to work with the
developer to say the last remaining part
of green space that is there could we
make it you can control the green yes
yeah okay there are no further questions
thank you very much
okay we'd go to our board member
counselor st. no other speakers
councillor st. welcome thank you for
waiting okay so you know the routine you
have five minutes
Thank You German over to you I shall
ignore the jibes mr. chairman I'm gonna
cover this
slightly different angle from the parish
council because this is a sensitive
piece of land and it is used for a
variety of reasons as councillor brain
has already alluded to this evening I'm
going to look at it firstly from one of
the cause of my objection and that is
the loss of carpark spacing around the
pub now I do this with a little bit of
trepidation because several times just
lately I've sat in this place and
appealed on parking grounds and the
committee is just completely ignored me
so but here you are always indefatigable
I'll try again
the issue is that the largest carpark to
the pub has effectively used for a
variety of purposes and I recall when I
was a member of this committee we
granted permission for the old chapel to
change use into a business premise there
was no parking and what happened was the
then owner of the pub decided and this
was part of the planning application and
decision to actually allocate land on
the pub car park for commercial but
commercial uses and that's not mentioned
in the report at all
secondly the village post office is
closed by very busy post office and
people use the pub car park for that
purpose and thirdly because of the
elderly or the older dwellings around
very few of them have got parking and
therefore they park on the cub pub car
park as well so therefore we can ill
afford to actually make a decision on
the prod car park without taking these
factors into account however the real
number of the situation is this the
housing situation because I bought the
entire core strategy and I shall refer
to a page and a half of it
and that is that the officer's report
uses a s10 has cropped up two or three
times tonight for justification and a
s10 quotes knowing types of residential
development that could be permitted in
small settlements none of which apply or
irrelevant to this particular site for
building three houses on part of a park
and the key issue today as 10 emphasizes
its the compliance with CS 15 and CS 16
of the core strategy without flicking
back to that as the lead member on the
development of the core strategy
this is ingrained in my mind of what is
in CS 15 and CS 16 and that is the LSP
issues and as has already been stated
the LSP limit on a category 3 village is
deemed to be 59 however this is often
dismissed by officers on the grounds
that we've got other things to consider
I think the committee has got to start
giving this policy a little bit more
weight because we have exceeded the 2000
limit that the inspect that was
positively insistent on putting in and
it was his choice not ours but we live
with it happily that's been exceeded and
then the update sheet confuses the issue
by referring to an appeal in Finney
Compton which is also mentioned in the
main report which has been determined as
not really being relevant at all and
carrying no weight so I'm asking you to
dismiss any bearing that may have come
from the
any Compton appeal and assess the facts
that we have but it's quite clearly
stated in the report I've another wedge
and another piece of paper to find it
and you'll be telling me I'm running out
of time soon so I'm gonna be quick and
it's listed on page 77 new bold on sound
has well exceeded its allocation by
virtue of the inspectors ruling that was
included for a category three local
service for this so what does the update
sheet say well not everywhere in local
service villages category three have
these questions been exceeded
therefore we've got a scope to shove a
few more in Newport I ask you to reject
that argument and reject it open
handedly
at the present time we have got ample
and total grounds to reject this
application on the grounds of policy C's
s 1610 seconds right okay and therefore
that is my major appeal to you tonight
to reject the application based on the
fact is that Newbold has exceeded its
housing numbers and is not obliged to
take any more on you on approach to
grant any more Thank You counselor any
questions for the water member it's hard
I suspect some of its tarmac sorry you
said it would file good design
characteristics
no but the point of this year is the
existence somebody said earlier it's
surrounded by older houses there are
some modern houses but they've been
built in stone in an exceedingly
traditional style so the whole look of
this area is very old and village II not
modern and urban so I think this is
ensure we avoid any construction which
is modern and I think that rather
precludes any developments on this site
I think the site has got a traditional
use and we should aim to sustain that I
think the last time I took a course in
activity on that site was when our MP
was holding an election meeting and we
had half the village around so yes we
made use really that day Thank You
cancellous a question from me I want to
go back to your comments in the report
you say on page 35 it will create over
development of the site and fail good
design characteristics of a new
development would you expand a little
bit more on that and do you also think
that it would cause any adverse impact
on the listed buildings
I simply embellish what I said a moment
ago the modern
development would effectively have a
heavy impact on the character of the
site which is 90% if not 95% buildings
of traditional style so you want me to
say a bit more no I meant specifically
the listed buildings as well that's all
well that's right yeah I mean listed
buildings are listed for specific
characteristics but they again they tend
to have a charm of their own and as we
heard on an earlier application at night
tonight in the report on the Browse
application there is an act of
Parliament that asks us to pay
particular regard to the impact of new
development on listed buildings thank
you very much okay points of
clarification so all the policies within
the core strategy carry full weight now
it's adopted so that includes CS 15 16
and is 10 and we're looking at the
principle of the development
nothing late very well I think you all
realize I'm in a pretty objection or
mood this evening I seem to be going
against the officers recommendation on a
number of things please don't take it
personally officers but I do have
objection to the site you might have
alluded that when I asked the the
question to the Parish Council I I do
feel that this particular development
would urbanize the center of the village
which has this open characteristics are
joined to the joined to the the public
house we have core strategy policies
that we fought for a long time to get
policy CS 15 CS 16 newbould on star has
had it's more than its fair share as a
local service village of development it
doesn't take any box for me this one and
their five I am totally compelled to go
with refusing the officers
recommendation agree with the parking
that issue that it's been raised I think
we should that's right and that was
specifically because say its purpose
yeah I think its loss of green open
space impact on the character of an area
design issues sensitive piece of land so
I'm Satan took any boxes for me
councillor fielding council bonds but I
do feel that this is parish council
would like to houses we started up with
for I think that was refused and then
the village is well over its target but
then think we can use that as a reason
for refusal but having modern buildings
on a green space looks yet still listed
building I don't think these over
development that's the only thing that I
can say therefore it should be refused
but if the file cancer want to with a
green space which is allocated and
agreed I think that would be a planning
game Thank You councillor bonds my
thoughts I'd like to second what
councillor brain has said to refuse this
these are the reasons I've come up with
to refuse so far I would like to the
precise word and this will have to be
maybe for delegated to officers but the
exceeding the core strategies number
numbers for local service villages
especially CS 15 and 16 that's my first
reason second reason will be the
overdevelopment of the site both in in
terms of poor design which is not in
keeping and the size bulk and mass of
the proposal as well as its adverse
impact on the listed building so broadly
speaking two reasons the first one being
exceeding the numbers of the core
strategy and the second one
eating broadly to the developments owed
over development in the poor nature of
design those my two reasons can I
comment on that you mean the listed
building
yeah what so it would be three reasons
as far as a second reason to do with the
overdevelopment of the site to the
urbanizing effect it would have to the
center the village council bonds because
we were advised the other week not I
think we should take a steer from the
committee does anybody propose of course
counts the brain would you object right
you mind going through those reasons
so the first reason is that it would
exceed the housing numbers in CS 16 and
you want that as a reason on its own so
with respect to that all the many links
to sustainability you want to refer to
was it just exceeds the housing numbers
okay it's more sustainability of the
dispersal of development through the
plan period is that what you were found
to just referring you back in fact first
recent refusal their reasoning in terms
of the second reason from what you said
I understand that I forgot the proposed
development by reason of its poor design
and it would be out of keeping and an
over development which would encroach
into the open nature experience in the
locality of the site is that something
that leading to a feeling of
urbanization and the final reason will
be on the Heritage yes in terms of the
second reason is it character of the
area policy cs9 and cs5 that you're
referring to which relate to landscape
and and then the final reason is similar
to number two I understand that by
reason of the overdevelopment design
loss of the openness would have an
adverse impact on the setting and
they're all the special interest of the
heritage asset to the east of the site
yes and list it and then that's relating
to cs8 then I understand okay right okay
we have a proposition to refuse which
has been seconded with a number of
reasons stated should we go to the vote
all those in favor of refusing please
show
perfect thank you so therefore the
committee resolves to refuse application
reference 16 / 0 1 3 2 5 / ful and that
I think is our last item tonight that's
it thank you very much every meeting
closed